and and you know this is like any other
story that becomes
a day-to-day event for us we don't go
looking for it
we react to the news that is given to us
and the news that was given to us
yesterday included
an item from bob mcginn now of the
author
of the athletic long time writer at the
milwaukee journal sentinel covered the
packers for years
he reported among other things that in
group text messages with teammates aaron
rodgers
has mocked general manager brian gouda
kunst or as brett favre called him
on farm's podcast this week gutenhurst
which is butchering it even more than
you ever have
but rogers mocked gouda kunst calling
him
jerry kraus in text messages
with teammates which is as
professional athletes go in relation to
general managers the height of an insult
given the way that the bulls
players regarded jerry krause even
though he did put together a team that
won six championships
all gm should be jerry crouch seriously
that perspective you're right but but
based on last year's documentary the
last dance a 10-part extravaganza that
was riveting for anyone who cares about
sports yeah jerry kraus not something
you'd want to be called if you're a gm
of an nfl team
no i mean definitely not but you know
we're we're talking about a situation
that's
somewhat similar i mean it's it's it's
two star
players michael jordan who wasn't happy
with the way
things were run on the bulls and you
know whatever
acquisitions contracts all those type of
situations
rogers is you know i'm not saying he's
michael jordan but he's he's
damn close to that type of guy of course
is our league he's his biggest star as
we've had in football over the last 20
years not named tom brady
he's right up there with any of them and
yeah
i mean this is this is the kind of
ribbing
and things that happen when
you have an unhappy franchise
quarterback this is why you hear
when teams want to trade a quarterback
they want to make sure hey do you want
to be traded there because we want to
make sure you're happy
you know that next team wants to make
sure you're going to be happy here
and not cause problems in the locker
room and that's why teams try to avoid
any problems with their own starting
quarterbacks
because this is what happens oh yeah the
leader of the team you pissed him off
and he felt disrespected so now he
throws
you know jabs and and shots across the
bow all the time
at the team because he feels like he's
he's been wronged
what a shock that aaron rodgers yeah
would make
petty snarky snide
remarks yeah you could put yourself in
his shoes huh brian good kids
i've said it before i know i know got a
lot more in
common with aaron rodgers then we have
not in common but i will tell you this i
wouldn't be handling my business
the way that he's handled it yeah i hear
you last week i handled it far more
directly and i'd own it
and if i wanted out i'd say it not not
this game that's been
going on for over a week now and it is a
game and
i don't know whether he's going to win
or lose but it has been very
entertaining
and we'll see how it all plays out and i
i don't i like i i
i don't know where this one
came from this mcginn nugget because i
believe last week
everything that hit on thursday was
engineered by rogers and his camp
i don't know that the packers are
deliberately leaking things in an effort
to make him look bad
i think we're now at a point where there
are so many people looking for so many
different items to push the ball forward
that's right this could come from anyone
all it takes is one person who's on that
group text
to say yeah he calls him jerry krause
and there
there may be no nefarious motive there
just
being honest exactly yeah okay and yeah
right making a joke everybody watched
yeah we saw it yeah that was so so i i
don't know that someone deliberately
dropped this one into the right waters
of discontent to
ratchet it up but and i don't know i
mean gouda coons
didn't seem to be all that flustered by
the fact that rogers wants him fired
right i don't know that goody kunst is
going to react all that
strongly one way or the other to being
called jerry krause no gutenkos is a pro
i mean he he knows this is a tough
situation and i'm sure he
listen he'd be naive to think that like
what did he think aaron rodgers was
running around the
the stadium last year telling everybody
how awesome and how much he loved good
goose
i mean goody knows that the situation is
what it is this is business here in the
nfl and this is
what happens in these type of situations
and i'm with you too mike i don't think
this is something that was like
planted or put out there i think a lot
of people are looking for a lot of
information right now
and who knows it could have been
somebody on the group text or if there
was five guys on the team
on the group text hey one guy that
wasn't off and he go hey
you know he's sitting at a locker go
look look rogers rogers called goodie
you know jerry kraus it's funny right
the jordan documentary
i mean that it could be as easy as that
it really can so
yeah i don't think this was some planned
you know conspiracy or anything like
that uh it's
it's kind of what i would have expected
from aaron rodgers in this situation
last year
how for all anyone knows roger's been
calling him in the locker room guten
crouched or something like that yeah
right you know wait right it takes on a
life of its own exactly i start having
fun exactly right
but like you said and as we've discussed
yeah people looking to push the story
forward there was another item yesterday
this one came
from mike garafolo of nfl media
and this one surprised me i guess it
shouldn't i guess nothing
should surprise me at this point but i
was surprised by the report
that rogers told prospective free agents
on the green bay packers
in 2020 don't count on me being here
next year when you're making your
decisions about whether or not you're
going to sign
or re-sign now i don't was that a factor
for anyone
david bakhtiari signed and stayed
highest-paid offensive lineman in league
history at the time aaron jones running
back
signed and stayed i think after he
exhausted
the pre-tampering period of finding out
what else would or wouldn't be out there
with other teams and he got a pretty
good contract to stay put
with green bay but corey linsley left it
was it if i don't know whether it was a
factor or not
but if he truly was doing it that's the
kind of thing that
if you're a packers fan you look at and
say what dude man if you're gonna go
just go
don't don't what are you doing why are
you why are you trying to create
problems for the franchise that's going
to be left behind
if you leave don't sabotage just go
just go don't don't don't play these
games
and try to mess with what the team is
going to be or not be
when you're gone but yeah i mean it it
could
this could be a lot of different ways i
mean one it could be
sabotage like you're talking about you
know
two it could be a lot like really the
situation we just talked about
where you know hey you're at a thursday
thursday the o-line and the quarterbacks
go out to dinner and some of the running
backs show up and they're drinking a
beer and eating a steak and
you know guys are talking about man i
don't know i'm gonna be a free agent
next year and
you know they look over at rogers and he
just you know
i don't know i'm probably not gonna be
here i mean it could be just like that
again but again
these are the conversations and things
that happen when
you've kind of lame-ducked your
franchise
biggest star in the history of your your
organization
almost so i i again i don't know if i'm
sitting there
thinking as an ex-player because i do
think if rogers was like truly
being a jerk right and truly trying to
sabotage and being like
don't sign back here you're crazy i'm
not going to be here i'm out of here
this place stinks and do that i we're
going to hear those stories that's going
to come out if it went to that point
but if it's banter of just like oh they
don't want me i'm out of here anyways
don't sign back here like
it's more that just guys talking that's
how i would imagine it being
he's going to lose respect if he's truly
trying to
sabotage the organization that's like
against man code
football guy code whatever you want to
say guys in the locker room aren't going
to love that but if he's saying it kind
of just as a guy
and like i'm out of here then then
that's part of football and football
talk at times
well yeah but there's still a line there
that it doesn't matter the context it
doesn't matter the reason or the
motivation if you say something like
that it
is going to potentially impact the plans
made by
the players and look not every nfl
player and
it would be interesting to get the full
percentage of how this works they're not
motivated by
i want to go to a team that is going to
have a chance to win a championship
guys want to get paid that's right much
money as they can and they
should right they want to live in a
certain place they maybe don't want to
uproot their family and move there's all
sorts of factors that go into
definitely whether or not the
quarterback's going to be aaron rodgers
or jordan love
how big of a factor is it i don't know
and part of it may just be
if he said it guys like yeah it's just
aaron being aaron
yeah right right but but still
the fact that anything other than
neutral
anything other than nothing was said
about his future now and it's also
possible guys went to him and said hey
you think you're going to be back here
i'm trying to figure out what i'm going
to do
well i don't really know if i'm going to
be back yeah the the context could
change the perception it does
but still still the report
when it shows up on the nfl's official
tv channel and
it just it just paints a troubling
picture if you're a packers fan between
the distraction that he created last
week
deliberately i believe on the first day
of the draft yeah a time when
brian goody coons in the front office
had far bigger fish to fry than worrying
about
all of this acrimony with aaron rodgers
finally hitting the fan
on the busiest three days for a scout
and for a gm with all the work they've
got to do the decisions they have to
make everything that's happening
and this it he's running the risk and
and i think
what it really adds up to
silence is not an option
silence not healthy not going to fix
this no
if he wants to try to fix this he's got
to say
something and i'm not just saying that
because we want to have a clip to play
from aaron rodgers and we want more to
talk about tomorrow you don't care
you'll be in your hammock with your pina
colada in your blunt tomorrow
but but i don't care about
i don't care about having more content
i'm looking at this from the standpoint
of
trying to figure out where it's going
right figure out what we should and
shouldn't believe and by now
if there was any any fake news
cry to be uttered or any other qualifier
or effort to put toothpaste back in the
toothpaste holder
which is going to forever be the phrase
that we use and people are going to tune
in and say what are they talking about
other than the obvious but i i
i just think that if you're ever going
to make it be known
that any of this is false that any of
this
is exaggerated that any of this is
embellished the more time passes the
harder it's going to be
to get anyone to believe it because it's
getting baked in
chris it's baked in for a week now which
in nfl terms may as well be a year right
the news cycle goes well yeah
i mean there is there is some baked in
aspects to this whole thing
you know one i'm with you mike like
thursday i think it's a planned attack
right
i'm i'm with you a hundred percent like
strategic
planned attack you know up yours green
bay this is what you did to me a year
ago and here's the payback
i'm with you all the way there you know
this other stuff surprised you didn't
throw joe boo
i was about to i was about to i had a
bunch of things going through my head
there
but but you know the other thing too
of course with that aspect right you
know we talk about
the players too hey the players are
going to do what they got to do
as far as money and like you said you
laid it out there perfectly
but i don't think like any of these
other things again i think this is
normal football business type of
talk at least the way it looks to me
even the part of like hey i'm not going
to be here next year like listen i'm
sure tom brady
told some people on the patriots team
that like i don't know if i'm going to
be here next year
it ain't looking good i don't you know
what i mean i think it's part it's part
of what goes on once you get past
like week 12 of a regular season and
people know who's going to be a free
agent and who's not and
what's going to go on those
conversations start to come up a little
bit in the locker room and when you go
have a beer after
practice or whatever that is so there's
that aspect
at least to me and my experience and
being around it
but the other thing is too is you know
because rogers has
a passive aggressive history
and you know for lack of a better way to
say it cried wolf maybe one too many
times with these type of things
listen anything is going to be construed
and looked at
and dissected more than other players or
other people
because he's got a history and that's
his own fault to his own degree i can't
defend him there
but that's why you know guys like us and
other tv shows are going to dissect
almost every comment he makes
even though i think these were probably
like harmless
he's made so many other calculated
harmful type comments that are passive
aggressive
that you read into everything because
you go well he's done it eight out of
ten times so wait why wouldn't it be
nine
ten out of ten and i don't think he's
done himself any favors
in that regard when it comes to this
type of stuff because we're all
looking for that what is rogers really
saying what's his master plan what's he
really doing here
what's he mean by that and he's done
that to himself
uh with his own reputation and one of
the realities of this
based upon the way stories like this
have played out in the past once the
relationship
reaches defcon one yeah which is the
worst defcon you would think
five would be the worst you would right
on one basically means the missiles are
in the air
it always gets me like with the sprained
shoulder is it
is it a severe sprain if it's one or
three like which one's the more severe
three so now that one's the more serious
one see that's where i get confused i'm
sorry to interrupt you but i i
i hear you yes but i i always hear
people say defcon five and i say
not that crucial idea that's when it's
time to
put your head between your legs and kiss
your ass goodbye the old duck and cover
caveat but uh
what he needs to realize and what anyone
else needs to realize who may be
plotting a situation like
this in the future and i have a thought
on that that i'll try to sneak in here
before we take our first break but
once it happens that's when the
horde of reporters starts
scouring the countryside for anything
they can find to add to it
so if you are planning something like
this and you're
you know a quarterback any whatever
player coach whoever
if you're planning some sort of an
effort to get out from under your
current contract
and you expect at some point it is going
to get to defcon
54321 yeah
the the entirety of the last year is
going to be fair game anything you said
cannon will be
used against you if one of the many
reporters who are covering the nfl can
ferret it out and so this isn't a
surprise
that the feeding frenzy would grab
anything it can
and present it in an effort to keep the
story alive
to push the story forward because i
didn't like there's a whole lot else
going on right now either
that's the other side of it number one
he hijacked the draft
number two he's hijacked the week after
the draft number three there's nothing
to knock
aaron rodgers off the top of the stack
no you're right there's nothing going on
in sports that's that major right now
and it and it's aaron rodgers i mean
it's you know
other than tom brady and lebron james
i guess in patrick mahomes right i mean
i'm in the pecking order of sports
icons right now maybe steph curry might
be right there above them a hair
i mean this is this is the biggest
sports guy in our country and of course
you know
my thoughts on him i think he's the
greatest quarterback to ever live
so yeah there's this this is we're gonna
pay attention
and he's got a history of being
mike florio-ish and snarky and doing
things like that
so yeah we're all gonna read into
everything he does
and we know how smart he is and
everybody always tells us that no matter
who you talk to
and we know how calculated he is too and
how much he pays attention to everything
so it's hard to believe that things
you're a mistake or anything
like that and especially with a guy yeah
like rogers who's without a doubt one of
the five biggest sports stars in our in
our country
think about the month of april he had
the two weeks
of hosting jeopardy that was taped back
in february but the two weeks and it
unfolded and it was great and he got
great reviews and there's speculation
could he play for the packers and host
jeopardy at the same time and
while all of that was still lingering in
the ether
that's when all this other stuff
happened it has been a crazy four weeks
it's really hard for
the packers and for aaron rodgers
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports